(men grunting)
(punches being thrown)
- [Narrator] You've probably
seen this countless times.
The shaky cameras, the fast cuts,
and just plain overall mayhem.
It's sometimes so bad
that you may ask yourself,
"What am I watching?"
So how did we exactly get to this?
Let's rewind a bit.
The one common denominator
among older action films
is clarity and it makes sense.
Earlier action films,
especially martial art pictures,
focused on showing the
physical feats of its stars.
To achieve this, scenes were
often shot in a wide angle,
with most of the body
visible in the frame.
The camera also rarely
moves and when it does
it follows the actions of its characters
to accentuate speed and power.
But modern action movies
aren't shot this way anymore.
Instead they're choppy, chaotic,
and a lot of times just confusing.
When you compare these
movies side-by-side,
the difference is unmistakable.
But perhaps the real shock
comes when you realize
that most of this is actually intentional.
So back to the question, how
did we get to this point?
Well, it's impossible to
pinpoint a specific source,
but one of the biggest influences was
probably the original Bourne Trilogy.
These films were revolutionary
in the action genre,
not to mention both a
commercial and critical success.
And from jittery, hand-held
cameras to rapidly firing cuts,
you can trace all the problems in
modern action films to this series.
An easy way to see how the Bourne Trilogy
changed action films is by looking at
the average shot length, or ASL for short.
It's a cinematic statistic that measures
the average length of
a scene before a cut.
In the first film, Bourne Identity,
the ASL was around four seconds,
which then became 2.4 seconds in
its sequel, Bourne Supremacy.
And in the final film, Bourne Ultimatum,
a total of about 3,200 shots were
squashed into a 105-minute running time.
That's a cut happening almost
every two seconds of the film.
Another change you can
notice is in the camera work.
Doug Liman in Bourne
Identity shot his sequence
more like the classic action
cinemas we're used to;
wide angles and fewer cuts to capture
the action as clearly as possible.
But under Paul Greengrass's
direction the camera
becomes a lot shakier
and closer to the action.
He prefers his audience
to experience the film
rather than to simply observe it,
and that's what Bourne really
is, it's an experience.
The series is actually
edited in a similar way
our consciousness and
sensory perception works,
how we gather bits of information
to create a larger hole.
It's especially evident
in chase scenes like this,
where we see everything
from Bourne's perspective
and are given the chance to interpret
different clues to track down a target.
There is an intensity
to these films that we
can't quite place and the secret lies in
how Greengrass chooses to
shoot an action sequence.
Although every cut and angle seems
choppy, chaotic, and mostly random,
once you take a closer look at it
you realize that everything
serves a purpose.
Not everyone dedicates the same amount
of thought like Greengrass and,
sadly, it's made for some pretty
terrible action films in recent years.
There's a reason Hollywood
was so quick to adopt
Greengrass's style
because fast-paced editing
makes it easy to use visual trickery
to turn anyone into an action star.
All it requires is to put
three different shots together.
Action,
impact,
and reaction.
This is why you often see a
cut right before the impact,
then a cut to the moment
after the impact takes place.
They cut to hide the action.
This not only makes the action look fake,
but it kills the overall
momentum of the scene as well.
But in Bourne, each
cut is a deliberate act
to quicken the pace of the film.
It's never really used to hide anything.
Every hit, every impact,
is fully delivered
in front of the camera.
The camera doesn't cut until the blow
has been fully registered,
making the fight more
authentic and engaging.
The combination of action,
impact, and reaction
still exists in this method of editing.
It's just not as obvious
when replicated incorrectly.
And although Greengrass
does sacrifice some level
of clarity for the sake
of adding intensity,
it doesn't mean he's
abandoned it completely.
In fact, when you watch any of the
action sequences from the Bourne series,
you'd be surprised to notice that
it isn't as confusing as it first appears.
There are clever tricks at play here,
if you know where to look.
First, check out the frequent use
of wide-angle shots like these.
They let the audience understand the space
and the placement of each character.
Sometimes in an obvious angle as this,
from above as the fight
moves on to a new location.
Or how most of the blows, the impact,
and brief inserts whenever a new weapon
is acquired are all centered on the frame;
guiding our focus, gathering these
hints of information more quickly.
Now, let's look at bad examples.
The biggest problems in films that try to
imitate the Bourne style is that they
take it too far, exaggerating everything.
For instance, in this scene, you can see
the fast cuts kind of
like the Bourne style,
but it's paired with the same shot
repeated numerous times
in rapid succession.
We've seen repetitions
in past action films
hundreds of times but not
quite to this extreme,
and let's admit it,
there's no reason to watch
Liam Neeson jumping over
the same fence 10 times.
Even in car chase sequences where
repetitions are bound to happen,
one impact is enough if shot correctly.
(cars squealing and sliding)
Or even in music, most
recent films have a track
that plays throughout the
entire action sequences,
setting the pace and
sometimes fading it out
to accentuate key moments like this.
(man screaming)
But it's the entirely opposite in Bourne.
(intense percussion music)
There is no music.
What builds momentum and tension
is the actual sound of the action itself.
Every sound, from the brutal impact to the
various tools of combat creates a rhythm,
a beat without a single note.
(man throwing punches)
(woman grunting)
(woman being hit)
All these small details
and tricks make the
action of Bourne more
coherent and more intense
than anything we've seen before or since.
It's a beautiful combination of what was
successful in traditional action films,
with a new, innovate technique.
Bourne can't be blamed for how bad
action films are these days,
but the blame is on the
filmmakers who are trying
to replicate its technique
and failing miserably.
Audiences are smarter than
what some directors believe.
We can easily notice when
we're being manipulated
to see and feel in a way
that is not natural to us,
and perhaps that's what
differentiates Bourne
from so many of its predecessors.
It knows that editing can be used
to make anyone an action star,
but not necessarily a good action film.
And it's aware what this genre of cinema
is really about in the end,
action.
(gentle piano music)